de retour aux etats unis on a appris à
mieux connaître joe biden au fil de
cette campagne présidentielle hors du
commun aux états unis n'est pas encore
officiellement à la tête du pays le plus
puissant de la planète mais on s'est dit
que ce serait quand même important d'en
savoir encore plus sur le candidat
démocrate la journaliste de français
sonia dridi basé à washington vient de
publier sa biographie joe biden le pari
de l'amérique en titre home peu bonjour
sonia bonjour alors on reconnaissait
surtout comme ancien vice-président
américain aux côtés de barack obama et
vous avez hésité avant d'écrire la
biographie joe biden parce que vous
pensiez à ce moment là que c'était un
homme sans trop d'histoires sans trop
d'éclat
vous avez peut-être finalement écrit et
la biographie sur le futur président
américain
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que au départ
lorsqu'on m'a proposé d'écrire ce cette
biographie je me suis dit est ce que
j'aime bien le passionné dans ce que je
fais je me suis dit eux john hayden a
priori séparera personnage passionnant
c'est un homme politique très lisse
était en effet l'ancien vice-président
de barack obama mais depuis il a pris il
a vieilli flotte aujourd'hui dans ses
costumes bref ce n'était pas quelqu'un
même qui ont tous dit assumer beaucoup
le parti démocrate
mais très vite en commençant à faire des
recherches et bien je me suis rendu
compte que c'était qu'elle est vraiment
un personnage ans est fascinant qu'il
avait une vie romanesque il était
beaucoup plus complexe qu'on ne le
pensait et finalement je me suis
beaucoup amusé et j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant d'écrire son histoire
donc ça devient passible d'amendés
prendre une autre tournure quand même
d'écrire la biographie
de joe biden on attend bien sûr les
résultats aux états unis de cette
élection mais à 78 ans joe biden sera le
président des etats-unis le plus âgé de
78 ans parce qu'il les aura dans
quelques jours il ya eu tout un parcours
au plan politique parce qu'il était
devenu le plus jeune sénateur de
l'histoire américaine à l'âge de 29 ans
n'est ce pas tout à fait il a été élu à
29 ans dans une élection déjà à l'époque
personne ne pensait que joe biden est
allé gagner parce qu'ils étaient face à
un sénateur républicain qui était même
soutenu par le président nixon à
l'époque qui n'avaient jamais perdu une
élection et contre toute attente le
jeune joe biden a remporté cette
élection donc à 29 ans alors il était
vraiment sommet de la gloire aux côtés
de sa première femme mais via l de leurs
trois enfants
et puis quelques semaines après cette
victoire historique et bien elia et leur
petite fille naomi de 13 mois sont
décédés dans un accident de voiture en
allant chercher un sapin de noël
leurs deux fils ont été grièvement
blessées et ça a été vraiment est
évidemment un immense traumatisme pour
joe biden qui dit même avoir pensé au
suicide
il a voulu ensuite se retirer du sénat
parce qu'il voulait s'occuper de ses
deux fils et finalement et bien il a été
convaincu par ses proches de garder son
siège de sénateur alors il a dit bon je
vais me donner six mois finalement il
est resté trente six ans au sénat mais
son histoire c'est vraiment une histoire
pas que les américains parce que c'est
c'est une histoire un peu de survive de
survivants il a beaucoup de résilience
il a beaucoup de défauts aussi mais
c'est vrai que son empathie aujourd'hui
dont on parle beaucoup s'explique en
partie par son histoire personnelle et
comment vous pouvez nous décrire l'homme
sur lequel vous avez enquêté pendant des
mois vous avez parlé à certains de ses
proches également à quoi s'attendre
d'une présidence so joe biden alors
c'est vrai tout d'abord ce qui apparaît
assez évident c'est que c'est un homme
sympathique
j'ai parlé à des démocrates et à des
républicains qui m'ont dit m
on sent qu'il plaît un peu à tout le
monde et il ya même un ancien conducteur
de train pl à qui j'ai parlé qui
habitèrent winton la ville où habitent
toujours jo balden et où il est élu
sénateur qui est un républicain et qui
se présente ce qui s'est présenté cette
année au congrès et qui me disait moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec les idées
de joe binder mais lorsque j'étais
conducteurs de train parce que joe
bailon prenez le train tous les jours de
wilmington à à washington pour passer du
temps avec sa famille ce conducteur de
train a dit c'était vraiment l'homme
politique le plus sympathique
et puis on je sais aussi que l'insee
grave aujourd'hui un proche de donald
trump disait il ya quelques années
si vous n'aimez pas joe biden c'est que
vous avez un problème donc c'est
vraiment un homme du compromis lorsqu'il
était au sénat il a toujours parlé aux
républicains et aux démocrates
il est aussi fidèle en amitié j'ai
rencontré l'un ses premiers ennemis afro
américains ils se sont rencontrés
lorsqu'il avait 19 ans et joe biden est
encore en contact aujourd'hui avec lui
très souvent il est conseillé parfois
par cet ami afro américain will smith et
c'est aussi pour ça que il est populaire
aujourd'hui auprès des afro américains
en majorité par ce qui s'est toujours
battu pour les droits civiques mais
aussi c'est un personnage beaucoup plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraissait pas juste
être hommes politiques vieillissant un
peu has been il a un sacré caractère
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on l'a vu lors il
n'était pas avec donald trump lorsqu'il
a dit vous voulez pas vous la fermer sa
g a répondu effectivement il y avait
répandu à ce moment là et donc à écouter
ça nous donne un bon portrait de la
chose
j'invite quand même les gens à aller
lire votre biographie de joe biden le
pari de la mairie quand tu trompes aux
éditions du rocher sonia dridi merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
merci beaucoup au revoir